ان نبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل من باكستان حيث
وافاد مراسل العربيه بسقوط جرحى في انفجار
في مسجد
ببيشاور شمال غرب باكستان
وقواته الامنه تطوق المنطقه الشرطه
الباكستانيه عبرت عن مخاوفها من سقوط عدد
كبير من القتله جراء الانفجار في بيشاور
نتابع معكم هذه الصور من موقع الانفجار
حيث تحدثت وسائل اعلام عن انفجار الكبير
هذا احد المساجد في منطقه بشاور
الباكستانيه
والانباء حتى الان وكما نشاهد في همم
الاخبار العاجله من احد مسؤولين مستشفى
بشاور اكثر من 70 جريحا بينهم عدد من
الحالات الحرجه بعد تسجيل همم المسجد كما
ان مسؤولا في شرطه الباكستانيه كان قد
اعلن انفجارا هذا احد المساجد في مدينه
بيشاور قرب الحدود مع افغانستان
واشار الى ان هناك مخاوف ايضا من سقوط عدد
كبير من الضحايا حسب ما تفيد الانباء حتى
الانتظار